Ying: Uh, this is
Implementing Money Making SDKs.
Thanks for coming today.
How many of you guys
went to the, uh,
Build a Mobile Business,
Not Just a Mobile App yesterday?
Okay, so about half
of you guys.
So, um, this is, uh, Dean Browne
and Paul Hounshell.
I'm Mike Ying.
Uh, we are three
of the engineers
on the mobile display
ads team,
and we're gonna talk you through
a little bit about, uh,
implementing ads
in your application,
and then also some
of the best practices
and ways of making sure that
people are gonna see your ads,
uh, click on your ads,
and, make you some money.
So first, there's the QR code.
If you have any feedback for us,
uh, scan that,
tell us what you think.
Also, if you're tweeting today,
use hash tag io2011
and hash tag GoogleAPIs.
All right, so, um,
today, what we're gonna do
is we'll just kind of go
through a quick overview.
We're gonna run through
the code parts of this talk,
um, relatively quickly.
Everything we're gonna show you
today is also gonna be available
at our web site.
It's code.google.com/mobile/ads.
We'll have that up at the end
of the talk, as well,
so you can see it.
Um, so we'll talk about--
a little bit about the setup,
the integration
on three platforms--
Android, IOS, Windows Phone 7.
We'll talk you through
a little bit about
the tracking and the reporting
after that,
and then some
of the best practices and FAQs,
and we'll try to keep some time
at the end for Q&A.
Okay, so, um,
for those of you that didn't go
to the session yesterday,
what's a money making SDK?
Um, the AdMob network is a way
for basically
you to show ads
from our advertisers,
and every time someone clicks
on an ad, uh, you get paid.
And we take a share of that,
you get a share of that,
and, uh, you get paid.
So first step,
go to www.admob.com.
Uh, you can register today
with your Google account.
This is, uh, the same
Google account you use
for whatever other services
you're using with Google.
Um, if you're
an Android publisher,
use the same Google account
that you use
on the market publisher's site.
Um, you'll add a site--
that comes from the old days,
if you guys remember WAP,
when there were still
mobile web sites.
Um, so you can
basically use a site
anytime you want to show an ad
in any of your applications.
We recommend using
multiple placements
and multiple site I.D.'s
for each of those.
We'll talk a little bit about
that a little bit later today.
And then you pick your platform
and you download your SDK.
So if it's Android,
you'll get a jar,
if it's IOS,
you'll get a static library,
and so on and so forth.
So first, we'll talk you through
the Android platform.
So for our demo,
what we use--
we use Eclipse,
we use the Android SDK,
and we use the ADT plugin
for Eclipse.
Um, none of this
requires Eclipse.
You're welcome to do
whatever development
environment you like.
Um, we simply give this library
to you as a jar,
and you integrate it
into your project.
Uh, so what I'll
walk you through is,
first, you have to add
the ad's SDK
to your project and build path.
I'll kind of gloss over that.
That's already done for you
in the demo.
And then add the AdView
to your layout XML,
and ad the AdActivity
to your manifest.
So if you just want to do
a very simple,
uh, ad integration,
and you don't really
care about, uh,
any sort of targeting
or anything like that,
you just want to show an ad
and make some money,
this would be one
of the easiest ways of doing it.
Uh, you take the AdView--
it's a class
that we give to you--
you'll request
a particular size.
In this case,
this is a banner.
That's 320 pixels by 50 pixels.
Um, in the case of Android,
we tell you to use
device independent pixels.
This way, you get an ad
that looks good on any device,
whether it's a, you know,
a Nexus S
that's in high density,
or one of the old, say,
G1s that's in the regular,
uh, you know, single,
uh, 1.0 density.
Um, in this case,
the main layout
has been named,
uh, "Main Layout."
It's a linear layout,
so we find that view
by its I.D.,
then we add the AdView
to the layout,
and then what we do
is we create an ad request.
Um, an ad request is basically
giving all the information
that you need,
uh, to give us--
so that we can target
the ad appropriately.
This includes things
like keywords,
uh, whether or not you want
this to be in test mode.
So in this case,
for testing,
uh, we set up
a particular test device.
This is one of our test devices,
and you set it up
as a test device
to ensure that you get only ads
in test mode,
meaning we won't charge anybody.
You'll just see this ad.
It's more likely
that you'll get an ad back,
and then you'll
just be able to use that
to see that
it's working correctly.
So once you've set that up,
you simply put that in
and load the ad,
and it will show up.
So let me switch over, and I can
kind of walk you guys through
what it looks like, uh,
with a few other,
um, enhancements.
So, uh, to start out,
we'll walk you through some
of the changes that are required
in the Android manifest.
This is where you
specify information
about your application.
Uh, you can see, what we did
is we took the snake example
from the Android examples.
It's basically
just like the snake
on the old Nokia phones,
where you're a little line,
and you're running around
trying to grab these dots
that are apples.
Okay, first, what we did
is we added two permissions.
Uh, first is
the internet permission,
and second is the access
network state permission.
Uh, we need those two,
obviously,
to get out to the ad servers,
and then also to check
and see if, you know,
you're on WiFi or 3G.
That's part of the ways
that we'll decide
what kind of an ad
to show you.
Um, one other thing
that we ask you to do
is also to add
an ad activity from our jar.
Um, what this does
is this allows us to, uh,
show particular landing pages
that don't take you outside
of the application flow.
Uh, sometimes this will happen.
We'll use it
when it's appropriate,
and, you know, the basic idea
is that we want to make this
as seamless as possible
for users,
so that it doesn't feel
like they're getting,
you know, pulled out
of the application.
Okay, so next,
um, the snake layout.
Now what we've done is,
we have
a basic linear layout here.
Uh, there's an AdView in XML,
and then a frame layout,
which is where the snake game
is actually played,
so, uh, you'll see right here,
the AdView here
is being specified
as 320 device independent
pixels wide,
and 50 device
independent pixels tall.
Uh, we've also specified
an ad unit I.D.
This is just
a little bit of a--
it's a little bit
of a departure that we make
from the terminology
used on the web site.
Uh, back in the old days,
when everything was WAP,
uh, they were all called
site I.D.'s or publisher I.D.'s.
Uh, we try to call them
ad unit I.D.'s
in the case of apps.
Um, a little bit later, we'll
talk about different placements
and why you might want
to name different ads
inside your application
with different I.D.'s.
And then the last item
is the ad size,
which is the banner.
It's 320 by 50.
And then now,
let's take a look at what we do
in the snake activity.
So, uh,
at the point at which
we had left it
with the manifest
and the layout,
you can probably--
would've gotten to see an ad
no matter what,
but here, what we're doing
is we're making sure
that this ad request
is being requested,
"A," in test mode,
and then I'll show you
a little bit about
the ad listener call back
interface that we set up,
so that you can do a little bit
of different things,
depending on whether
an ad comes back,
when the screen, uh,
when a screen is being shown
over your application,
and so on.
So to walk you through,
first, we find the AdView,
as named in the snake layout,
we set the ad listener
as, uh, this particular class,
and then we create
the test request.
Um, here, what we do is,
we basically just say,
for the emulator, make these
ad requests in test mode.
Um, it's important to do most
of your testing in test mode,
only because, uh, you know,
we don't want to be testing
with live traffic
until we're basically
ready to, uh,
submit the app
into the market, okay?
So from here,
we set the test devices,
and then we load the ad.
Now that could really be
all you need to do.
Uh, what that will do is,
that makes the request,
gets the ad.
We handle everything
from that point on.
If the user clicks on it, um,
that's great.
Uh, one thing, what we've done
here for this particular demo
is tried to give you
a little bit of polish
around how the ad shows up.
So here, we have an ad listener,
uh, callback.
This is on receive ad.
This is basically what happens
when an ad actually loads
for the user.
So in this case, I have
sort of two animations set up.
I decided just to use
the scale animation here.
Uh, what this means
is when the ad shows up,
we're gonna take this,
and we're gonna zoom in the--
we're gonna kind of
zoom the ad in as it shows up,
so over half a second.
And then two other things we do
are when we--
we will let you know
when the user
has clicked on the ad
and is about to leave
the application.
Uh, this is just so that
you can know if,
in the instance of snake,
maybe I want to pause this,
uh, maybe I want to pop up
an options menu
or something else like that,
just so that, you know,
when they come back, they're
not in the middle of dying,
running into the wall,
or something like that, right?
All right,
so now let's, uh,
take a run through this,
and we'll show you...
So snake, it just says
"Press up to play,"
so you can start playing.
At the same time,
the ad request is being made,
and if our wireless network
works,
then you will see an ad.
Otherwise, you might not.
Let me try it one more time.
All right,
we have the demo gremlins.
But you'll see.
In this case, what we didn't do
is we didn't, uh, change--
we didn't add any code
for what to do
when the ad does not show up,
So "OnFailedToReceiveAd."
Uh, this happens sometimes,
uh, you know,
if there's a network problem,
we can't get to the network,
uh, we won't show an ad.
There are definitely things
you can do in that case
to try to show something else
in that spot.
That could be one of your own
house ads.
That could be, um,
a different ad network.
We don't--we have no problem
with you using other ad networks
if you want, um, and then we'll
talk a little bit about that
at the end, as well.
So let me come back,
and we will hand off to Dean
to talk a little bit about IOS.
Browne: Thanks, Mike.
[quietly]
Can you guys hear me?
[normal voice]
No? There we go.
Can you hear me now?
man: Yes.
Browne: All right.
Hi, my name is Dean Browne.
Uh, I am also with Google,
I came over from AdMob,
and have been doing this
for a little while.
I'm here today to talk about
the IOS, uh, Google AdMob SDK.
And moreover, I'm here to talk
about tablets.
Um, I think everybody
in the room
has probably worked with ads
on mobile phones before,
and there's a lot
of similarities in tablets,
but there are
a few differences.
There's just different ad sizes
and different sort of usage.
But I'd encourage you all
to think about, uh,
building your app and extending
it to tablet right off the bat.
Um, tablets are--you know,
it's where people go
for casual computing,
and if you're gonna
have ads in something,
it's likely a casual
sort of thing--
a game, news reading,
whatever it is.
Um, and so it's good to know
a little bit about
what's available to you.
So the first thing
I'd like to talk about
is what ad sizes are available,
and sort of where to put them.
I think when everybody
thinks of a phone,
it's pretty standard now.
It's usually an ad
that goes across
the whole width of the phone,
and you just kind of
put it somewhere.
But what other sizes
are out there for tablets?
So obviously, since I'm talking
IOS, I'm talking iPad here,
but, uh, you guys all have
your fancy new Galaxy tablets,
uh, and they're
the similar resolution.
They're a little bit more, uh,
designed to be in landscape,
but all the same ad sizes
are the ones we support,
and they look roughly the same
as the slides you'll see.
So the first, uh,
ad banner size
that I'd like to talk about
is the medium rectangle.
This is the most common ad size
you see online.
I see it on ESPN
every day I go there.
And it's the same one--
the same size that
we support in the SDK.
It's 300 pixels wide
by 250 pixels tall,
and you can see it here.
It fits really nicely inside
a UI split view.
Um, UI split view
and a lot of iPad constructs
are about 320 pixels wide,
the--so that gives a nice little
10-pixel border around it.
Uh, this also works really well
on all the Honeycomb sizes,
as well.
Uh, and there's
a medium rectangle in portrait.
Uh, again, the exact same thing.
It looks and works
really nicely.
Uh, the next size I'm gonna
talk about is a leaderboard.
This is the second most common
size that you'll find online.
It's the same one. It's 728
pixels wide by 90 pixels tall.
In this case, it's portrait.
This is from the demo
that I built.
I'll show you
a little bit later.
And in this case, it goes,
uh, pretty well across
the width of all the screens.
It works--
it looks really nicely,
again, in landscape.
I've seen it used in
a lot of "Game Over" screens,
things like that.
Um, this is a very common one
I've seen done on tablets.
A lot of people choose this.
Those are the main two sizes.
There's a third size
that we support,
which is the full banner.
It's another online
standard size,
and it's just used
less frequently.
Uh, it's 468x60 pixels,
and the use case for this
is a lot--
uh, especially in the iPad,
there are a lot
of sort of overlays,
so there's UI form sheets
and presentation controllers,
things like that, and it's
a good size to fit in that.
So here's a--here it is
in just a form sheet,
and there it is
in a pop-over controller.
In both cases, uh, you--
the constructs don't have
quite as much screen real estate
as the whole screen,
and it's just another option
available to you.
All of these banner sizes
work much better
than a standard 320x50,
which is just dwarfed
on the size of a tablet screen.
It gives a lot more real estate
to advertisers,
and we see
really good performance.
Um, in general,
I would also say that tablets
we see really good, uh,
performance in, as well.
Very comparable to phones,
in some cases, actually better.
Uh, and the use cases
are very similar.
I mean, people are spending
a lot of time with their tablets
every day, looking at things,
they're discovering new content,
and ads is a great way for them
to be able to do that.
So with that,
I'm gonna go into the code.
Uh, the code is very
similar to, uh,
a normal iPhone, uh--
putting it in an iPhone,
like, a smaller,
uh, screen size,
as well as the Android code.
I'm gonna talk a little--
I'll demo all this again.
I'm gonna talk a little bit
about how you create the ad,
how you actually make
the ad request,
and then I'm gonna show
some effects,
uh, how to make the ad
look nice,
so I'm gonna drop a shadow,
and I'll have the ad fade in.
Um, all of these slides
are gonna be available online,
as well as this talk,
and the code
I will also release,
so the slides
aren't as important--
just wanted to cover
what we were talking through.
All right.
So this is the, uh,
this is a Feng Shui Compass.
It's, uh, just done, uh,
right now without any ads.
I'm gonna put an ad
at the bottom,
like you saw in the screen shot,
just above the, uh,
wood sort of paneling
in the background there.
Um, in general, you know,
that app has a lot of--
it looks really nice.
It's got a lot of detail.
I'm not sure that really
shows up on a slide,
but, uh, you want to make
your ad look nice.
You want it to appear
very professional
along with the rest of it.
So how do we go about
integrating an ad,
and then how do we go about
making it look great
in your application?
So the first thing
that we want to do
is we want to place the ad.
So this is some boilerplate code
that basically puts it above--
positions the ad
above the wood panel.
The one thing
I'd like to call out here
is that we are setting
the size of the ad
to the standard
leaderboard ad size.
Once you set the frame
for the ad,
the SDK will detect
that it's a leaderboard,
and will properly make the right
ad calls on your behalf.
The second thing
that we need to do
is we need to, uh, tell the ad,
What is the root view controller
of your application?
This is important because, uh,
it's how the ad knows,
when it's clicked,
how to take over the ex--
how to take over your,
uh, your app,
and start to show
the advertiser's content.
The next thing
is the ad unit I.D.
This is, in the AdMob case,
this is the AdMob site I.D.,
just like Mike
had talked about before.
You get this when you register
for, uh, on www.admob.com
for your site,
and that tells us
how to position
and create the ad.
And the final thing we need to
do is actually make a request.
So the only part
that's important here
is to just say, uh,
"bannerView LoadRequest."
In this particular example,
I'm gonna request, uh,
a test ad,
and I've white-listed
only the simulator
to receive test ads.
My actual device in this case
would receive a real ad.
So let's take a look and see
how this ad looks so far.
So if I...
just recompile it,
you can see the ad appear
at the bottom.
It's the same app
you saw before.
Uh, it's a little bit
hard to make out,
but there is a, uh,
new test ad that we're showing.
It's part of our new
App Galaxy campaign,
and those of you
that went yesterday
to the business portion of
making--of how to work with ads
will see it--
uh, guidetotheappgalaxy.com,
and see us later
for information on it.
This is a web site
that's just fantastic.
It just--it just shows you
about the business
of how to make money
with mobile advertising,
and just mobile in general.
Um, I suggest that all of you
go there if you have,
you know, questions,
if you're just trying to learn,
or even if you know--
uh, you think you know a lot,
there's still good content
in there.
I-I was really impressed.
It's a fun site.
So I have the ad appearing,
and I just want to click it,
make sure that everything works.
It does.
The App Galaxy ad--web site
is actually coming up
when I click on it.
Um, however,
it's a little bit hard,
again, to tell there,
but the ad doesn't
really look as polished
as the rest of the application.
You really want to make it look
like it's part
of your experience.
You just don't want
to dump it in.
You want to make
things look good.
So how am I gonna do that?
Well, I've used sort of lighting
and dropping shadows from things
throughout the rest
of the application,
so I want to do that
in the ad.
And the way that I'll do that
is I'm just gonna use
a normal CA layer drop shadow.
There's nothing specific
to the SDK in this call.
This just tells IOS to just
drop a shadow from the view.
The next thing I want to do
is I want to have
the ad fade in over time.
And so the way to do this
is I tell the view
to initially be transparent,
and then I set a delegate.
So a delegate is a lot
like a listener interface,
for those of you who
are coming over from Android.
It's just a bunch of methods
that I am optionally able
to implement to get
notifications from the SDK
when events happen.
In this particular case, by
registering myself as a delegate
and implementing the ad view
"DidReceiveAd" method,
I'm able to, uh,
tell--to be notified by the SDK
when an ad successfully
comes in, and then do something.
And in this case, all I'm doing
is making the transparent ad,
uh, go to fully opaque
over .4 seconds.
That's a standard, uh,
animation length you'll see
in Android and IOS.
It's sort of the,
"I saw something happen,
but it's not too slow" speed.
And so with that,
when I recompile,
you should notice the ad
in the same place,
but it'll slowly
fade in for you,
has a little bit
of a drop shadow.
Again, I apologize for how
it looks on the projectors,
but I encourage you
to all go grab the code
and take a look at it.
It's just a little bit sharper,
a little bit nicer experience.
You know, I can still see
that when I click the ad,
it still brings up my, uh--
it still works.
Everything's fine. I know
that everything's good to go.
And with this,
the app would be done.
So with that, I am done.
Please feel free to ask
questions later on.
I'm gonna turn it over to Paul.
He's gonna talk a little bit
about Windows.
Thank you guys.
You'll like it.
[applause]
Hounshell: Hi,
I'm Paul Hounshell.
I'm gonna show you
the Windows phone 7 ad SDK.
With this SDK,
we've really gone to, uh,
to match the functionality
in the phone versions
of the other two SDKs, um,
but we've taken advantage
of some of the Windows phone 7
features to make it even easier.
Um, today, I'm gonna
show you an example
of how to add it to
a Silverlight-based application.
If you don't know anything about
developing for Windows phone 7,
there's two models--
Silverlight and XNA.
And XNA is more of a game
programming model.
Silverlight is more of
a form space programming model,
and it's a little bit easier
to work with,
so it works well for a demo.
Um, our steps are--
are even easier.
We need to add the actual DLL
to your application,
and then we need to add
the control to our--
our layout.
This is basically it.
Um, you can see we've--
there's the ad reference
dialogue box,
and that's the XML
to add it to our display,
and so with that,
I'm just gonna cut to the chase
and show it.
So because this is the simplest,
I'm actually going
to live-code this.
I'm taking a risk here,
but, uh...
[laughs]
It's actually
really straightforward
to go through this process.
Um, so like I said, well,
the first step is to create
a brand-new solution
that we've never
worked with before,
and has absolutely nothing
prepared ahead of time in it.
And first, we add
our reference to the DLL...
which is...
already set for me.
And then we need to add
the actual,
uh, name space reference,
which, thanks to the--
to the benefit of IntelliSense,
it will automatically do
most of the work for me.
And then we need to add
the actual add control.
Um...
Then we grab that.
And that is it.
Our ad has been added
to our application,
um, and this should show,
uh, shortly,
when the emulator fires up.
There's our application running,
and our ad should pop in--
right there.
Now again, like in IOS,
we want to have a slightly
nicer aspect to this,
um, and that .4 second animation
really kind of makes it
a more gentle experience
for the user, which in turn,
leads the user to click
on things more often.
So adding that is using standard
built-in Windows phone 7
functionality.
Uh,
we can add
a storyboard animation,
Uh...
like so.
And we're gonna animate the--
the, uh, opacity.
So...
uh...
Like so.
And then I'm gonna give a name
to my ad,
and then last, I'm gonna
add in an event handler,
so that I can actually
handle this, uh,
the ad being received,
and fire up that animation.
I believe
that should be it,
unless I missed a step...
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Hounshell: Thank you very much.
I went a little too fast.
And there, the ad
fades in nice and smooth.
Um...
[applause]
Hounshell: Again, this is using
no special SDK functionality.
This is all using built-in
phone, uh, capabilities,
and so we've really worked
to integrate it
into the phone systems
in a nice, natural manner,
so that these things
are possible.
Um, with that, I'm gonna
turn it back to Mike
for talking about targeting
and--or, metrics,
and, thank you.
[applause]
Ying: Great, so now that
you guys know how to, uh,
integrate the SDK, we can
talk a little bit about,
uh, some of the more business
side of things.
Um, so how many people out there
remember from yesterday
what "requests," "impressions,"
and "fill rate" all mean?
Okay, so, uh, half of the people
that went to
the session yesterday,
uh, so we'll just over it
pretty quickly again for you.
Um, basically, every time
you ask the ad server for an ad,
that's an ad request.
Um, some percentage
of that time,
we will return you
an actual ad to show.
Uh, that's an impression.
And you basically
take that percentage--
that's your fill rate.
Um, of the impressions
that you serve, um,
people will either click
or they won't click on them.
We measure that as your clicks
over your impressions,
or your clickthrough rate.
And then, uh, based
on your clickthrough rate,
you have your revenue,
so if you have, you know,
1,000 requests
and let's say you get
1,000 impressions back,
uh, you have, um, you know,
50 clicks on that,
and say you're getting paid
5 cents a click,
you're gonna get paid
accordingly that way.
Uh, your eCPM is another
metric we use
to kind of measure the value
of your ads.
Uh, what that means is effective
cost-per-thousand impressions,
so what it means is, uh,
depending on what the--
what the cost per click is
for a particular ad, um,
you're--
the amount of money you make
based on 1,000 impressions
is going to fluctuate,
so we call that an eCPM,
and that's basically the average
for 1,000 impressions
that you get
from a particular ad network.
Um, as you guys probably, uh,
remember from yesterday--
if you, uh,
didn't see the session,
you should go
take a look at that--
eCPM fluctuates quite a bit
from, uh, day to day,
month to month,
and network to network.
So, um, it's a good idea
to kind of keep an eye on that,
and think about different ways
that you can help,
uh, maximize your revenue
between all this
eCPM fluctuation.
So, um, you'll see
in the AdMob UI,
um, this is a way of kind of
tracking some of this
business side information,
right?
Your revenue, your eCPM,
your requests,
your impressions--
they'll all show up
like this.
You'll be able to view it
day to day, month to month,
over pretty much
whatever time period you wish.
Um, so, you know,
you may go through,
and you may see that, uh,
on--for this particular app,
the fill rate is pretty good
to start,
and then it starts to drop off
a little bit.
This is one of our test apps,
so, uh, your mileage may vary.
So talking about some
of the best practices,
you know how to put an ad
in your app now,
and we've talked to you
a little bit about
how to kind of make the ad
look a little bit prettier,
so that it doesn't--you know,
so that it's not
just sitting there,
uh, stuck on top of
whatever application you have.
Um, it actually does pay
to, um,
think about how you're going
to place your ad, and, uh,
you know, where it's going
to live in your application.
Um, if you put--
if you put the ad in a place
where no one's gonna look at it,
no one's gonna click at it--
on it.
Um, so, you know, one
of the things we like to do
is we like to tell people,
"Create a separate I.D.
for each of your ad placements."
If you're gonna put one
on the front page of your app,
if you're gonna put one
in between levels,
uh, use separate I.D.'s
for those, uh,
for those particular ads.
Um, you know,
it may not be something
you're thinking about now,
but in the future,
you may want to be able
to control different things
on those ads
at different times,
so whether it's the presentation
and the color of that add,
or whether you want
to turn the add off
on particular parts
of your application,
um, this gives you
that kind of flexibility.
Um, because of that,
use descriptive names.
Otherwise, you'll forget
which, uh--
otherwise, you'll forget which,
uh, ad you're messing with,
and it's good to, you know,
don't play too many games
with your users.
And then also remember,
use ads in the right place,
and at the right time.
Uh, just because we showed you
guys a little bit of animation,
uh, it's not recommended
to have the ad
slide in under a user's finger.
We know when a click
is not very valuable,
and, you know, obviously,
those things may--
may seem like you might get some
more money, but it won't--
it won't work out the right way
in the end for you.
So, you know, things--
good times in a game
would be between levels
when the user's not particularly
worried about, you know,
messing up their game,
or, you know,
having to pause their game
just to get to the app--
just to get to the ad content.
And then also, you know,
stay away from controls.
We've seen sometimes
where people will stick an ad,
uh, right next to a menu bar,
or right next to, you know,
some other kind of button,
and it just tends to get you
sort of the accidental clicks
that end up not converting,
and, you know,
we're able to measure how
valuable these clicks are.
So it's better to make sure that
the people who are clicking
on your ads actually
want to see the ad content,
and want to, you know,
see more about the information.
So some other,
uh, you know,
frequently asked questions.
What happens when your app
changes orientation?
Uh, the ads, you know,
they act just like any other
piece of the UI.
They will rotate.
Um, one thing
that they do not do
is they don't scale to--
across the landscape.
So, um, that's sort of based
on the advertiser
really likes to have a very
fixed size of their ad,
so 320x50 is a standard
that the IAB,
which is the
Internet Advertising Bureau--
it's the standard
that they establish.
Um, so it does look
a little bit weird on landscape,
but once again, we encourage you
to think of good ways
of integrating that
into your landscape game
or your landscape application.
One thing we've seen
that works really well
is, um, we've seen
some games that have taken
the space that's remaining
between the side of the screen
and the end of the ad, and using
that as part of the scoreboard,
or something like that.
Um, it's better not
to just have, you know,
empty blank space
on each side of the ad.
It's good to think about,
you know,
What do you want to do
when you're showing
in landscape, uh, orientation?
And can my app be notified
if an ad call succeeds or fails?
Uh, yes, I think we showed you
the ad listener,
or the delegate,
or in all the cases of all
the callbacks that you'll get.
Um, we have callbacks for
the ad loading or not loading,
uh, when the application
is going to be closed,
or somehow obscured by content,
and those things
are really good.
It just gives your users
a good feeling,
like, it's okay for them
to click on the ad
if they know that
when they come back,
their app is gonna be
in the same state as it was
when they clicked on the app.
And, uh, can I specify
extra targeting information
to get better ads?
Absolutely.
Uh, some of the things
we let you put in there
are keywords, um,
we'll let you put
location information in there.
One caveat is that we ask you
only to give us
location information
if it's part of your app's,
um, you know, normal usage,
so if you are just a--
if you're a news application,
it might not be appropriate
to gather the location
just for the purposes of ads.
But say you're some sort
of mapping application,
and, you know, you're already
getting a location
as part of your user's normal,
um, you know,
walk through the application,
then that's something
you can give to us,
and we'll use that
to help target our ads.
And then also, uh,
what does "no fill" mean?
A lot of times,
you'll see "no fill."
That's going back to the idea
that not every impress--
not every request will get
filled with an impression,
so there are some cases
in which we'll feel
that it's not appropriate
to give back an ad,
and so not every request will
be filled with an impression.
That's okay. Uh, sometimes
it's just not the right time.
It's a temporary condition.
As you saw, sometimes future
requests will return ads.
And, uh,
this is going back
to the whole thing about eCPM
and fluctuation of fill rate,
plus eCPM.
We encourage you
to use mediation.
Uh, if you need to learn more
about mediation,
you can go to
Guide to the App Galaxy,
or reference back to the session
that we had yesterday.
Uh, it talks about some
of the mediation solutions
like adworld, at adworld.com,
to kind of go between
different ad networks
and be able to maximize
your revenue.
And so, uh,
some of those resources, um,
the code site is
code.google.com/mobile/ads.
We have, uh, information
about our SDKs
as well as example code.
We're gonna post
all of the examples
we showed today up there.
Also, inside each
of the distributions,
we'll have README and JavaDocs
as appropriate.
And then we have two groups.
Uh, one is more, uh, publisher-
and business-oriented.
That's for
nontechnical support--
that's that
AdMob Publisher Discuss there--
and then for the more
technical side of things,
you can go
to Google AdMob Ads SDK.
And then also, uh,
as you saw before,
we've got
the Guide to the App Galaxy.
That's how you
can really get an idea of,
okay, you've got this great app,
now what?
It'll give you a good idea
of all the different ways
that you can monetize,
uh, your application.
That's either
with paid downloads,
freemium models, uh,
house ads, direct sold ads,
and then regular
ad-supported applications.
All right, and with that,
uh, if there are any questions,
feel free to use the mics
up in the front.
man: Yeah, Bob James here.
Um, you mentioned, uh, the f--
leading, uh, in the full.
Can you--what's the difference?
They're kind of the same thing.
The dimensions
are slightly different.
Ying: Oh, so you were talking
about the leaderboard format?
man: Leaderboard versus full,
I think it was.
Browne: Versus the full banner?
man: Yeah, full banner.
Browne: Yeah, one is just
smaller than the other, yeah.
They're roughly
the same aspect ratio.
Um, the leaderboard
is just a much bigger size.
It's the one that you sort of
see at the top of the fold
on most web sites you go to.
It's like the sort of
topmost ad size.
It's, uh, it's a little bit
more common.
It's roughly, like, 70% wider,
so it's pretty good.
So if you take, like, the new
Galaxy tab that you just got,
it's gonna be 1280x800.
It's like roughly
the size of, like,
an A14
legal sheet of paper.
Most people hold it kind of
sideways, or whatever,
and so you'll see that
that ad will occupy
about 60% of the screen's width,
and just, you know--
I'd have to do the math,
but, like, 10%, 12%
of the height,
so...
man: Great.
Browne: Anybody else?
Ying: Okay, if there
are no other questions,
um, feel free--we have
office hours today until 5:00.
We're on the third floor.
Um, it's basically exactly
in this same spot,
just, uh, upstairs.
Feel free to come by if you have
any questions about the code
or any of the things
that we've shown you.
We're happy to sit down and talk
to you about all this stuff
or, you know, how to build
your business, as well.
Um, and then leave us
some feedback, tweet,
and, uh, thank you very much.
Browne: Thank you, everybody.